liebe zuschauer 22 uhr 32 heute an
diesem donnerstagabend hier sind unsere
gäste und das ist na klar unser thema
erst vier tage leben wir mit den neuen
regeln und noch wissen wir nicht ob sie
wirken aber schon wird nachgedacht über
die zeit danach wie lange kann man ein
ganzes land so herunter bremsen
wie hoch ist der preis darüber wird in
politik und wirtschaft schon diskutiert
dabei sind wir erst am anfang am anfang
der epidemie am anfang der welle ärzte
und pfleger bereiten sich auf den
gesundheitsnotstand vor dringend
gebraucht werden masken und
schutzausrüstung und vor allem
medizinisches personal über all das
wollen wir reden diesen gästen achim
tyler importeur von atemmasken und
medizinischer schutzkleidung
der am corona erkrankte
bundestagsabgeordnete alexander graf
lambsdorff
die krankenschwester yvonne folgt von
der fdp der arzt andrew ullmann
zugeschaltet aus frankfurt am main die
virologin sandra c6
und der spd politiker und mediziner karl
lauterbach
sie sind zu gast bei maybrit illner ja
ein willkommen unseren gästen hier heute
abend sie alle wissen wovon wir sprechen
seit vier tagen gibt es dieses
sogenannte kontaktverbot deutschland hat
sich verändert
die dinge vom ende her denken in der
krise schwieriger denn je
nun ist das land leer die mahnungen der
politiker wurden gehört die leute halten
sich an die neuen regeln
manchen ist mulmig es ist beängstigend
ist eigentlich einschüchtern
es ist natürlich ein unangenehmes gefühl
so aber es ist ich denke man kann es
aushalten dass man seine freunde und
familie jetzt so gut wie nicht mehr
sehen kann aber auch da finden sich ja
kreative lösungen also wir skypen jetzt
jeden tag die kurve runterdrücken das
tempo der neuinfektionen verlangsamen
jeder dürfte das inzwischen verstanden
haben
doch wie lange soll das weitergehen es
gibt keinen anlass zur entwarnung
sondern es gibt weiter anlass zu
disziplin disziplin die man sich leisten
können muss der shutdown kostet
milliarden und bedroht existenzen
aktuell sind wir von 100 auf null
gefallen haben keinen einzigen auftrag
mehr haben eigentlich komplett
durchgeplantes jahr 2020 reifen 14 tagen
verloren
die krise trifft alle kleine mittelstand
und dachs elite
corona könnte 1,8 millionen jobs kosten
fürchten wirtschaftsforscher der stadt
stemmt sich dagegen
wir werden alles tun was notwendig ist
um arbeitsplätze und unternehmen und
beschäftigung und die gesundheit zu
verteidigen wie lange hält deutschland
das aus die dinge vom ende her denken
jetzt ist die politik am zug
der gesundheitspolitische sprecher der
spd karl lauterbach sie sind arzt auch
epidemiologe wenn man sich anguckt uhr
es in deutschland geschieht die leute
sind für diese maßnahmen
sie halten sich daran ist der ball jetzt
tatsächlich wieder im feld der politik
weil sich natürlich alle wünschen dass
man auch über ein ende nachdem der ball
ist zum teil 1 teil also in unserem feld
wieder aber man muss tatsächlich also
eingestehen wir gewinnen jetzt nur zeit
wir lösen ja kein problem weil die gute
nachricht ist jetzt infizieren sich sehr
wenige die schlechte nachricht ist baut
sich natürlich auch keine immunität auf
das heißt die zahl derer die sich
infizieren können in zukunft wird nicht
weniger werden sie mit diesen
simulationsmodellen also sozusagen
schauen dass gewonnen wäre wenn man zu
früh
die maßnahmen lockern dann sind sie im
prinzip sogar schlechter dran als vorher
war sie haben dann sehr viel material
schon verbraucht und danach kommen die
fälle genau so rapide wie sie jetzt
gekommen wären und sie haben dann
überhaupt nichts gewonnen
das heißt das ganze nur zweck und da
gibt es verschiedene strategien das kann
man später darüber reden aber das ganze
hat nur zweck indem man das relativ
konsequent durchhält und dann auch die
maßnahmen nur ganz wenig zurück nimmt
dann wenn man sie zu stark zurücknehmen
dann kann man möglicherweise den appell
hat mehr schaden anrichten dass man
keinen wirklichen nutzen wir haben noch
einen arzt in unserer runde neben ihrem
bundestagsmandat für die fdp in rohlmann
sind sie infektiologe und arzt für
innere medizin
jetzt ist das für uns alle natürlich
eine besondere situation die einen
wünschen sich dass es möglichst lang
zusammen geht und andere nicht nur die
wirtschaft und die politik jeder normale
mensch wünscht sich dass es möglichst
ein schnelles ende gibt sie sind arzt
und politiker welches herz sieht gerade
in ihnen selbst ein doppelherz natürlich
ich bin aus leidenschaft aber genauso
leidenschaftlich auch politiker und
beide berufe bedingen ja auch
verantwortung verantwortung einmal für
die gesundheit aber auch verantwortung
für die gesellschaft die wir übernehmen
müssen und die maßnahmen die jetzt
ergriffen worden sind sind genau die
richtige wir müssen hart jetzt
eingreifen um die krise die wir jetzt
stecken auch möglichst schnell unter
kontrolle zu bekommen
die stimme meinem kollegen ja auch
hundertprozentig zu wir müssen sehen
dass diese welle abgeflacht ist damit
für unsere ressourcen aus sinnvoll auch
so einsetzen dass wir auch nie einsetzen
dass das nicht so lange rebound effekt
kommt wenn man mich zu früh alles
aufgeben
dann haben wir ein rückschlag dass wir
dann sehr schnell schlimmer werden und
das wollen wir nicht wir müssen dann
auch sehen wie sie es gesagt vom ende
her denken die wir für april
möglicherweise wieder abrüsten aber
momentan sieht die diese müssen jetzt
stark sein und als menschen ist jetzt
besonders herausgefordert weil wir
soziale wesen sind und gewohnt sind
miteinander in kontakt zu stehen absolut
bei uns ist yvonne falkner heute abend
sie sind hier in berlin krankenschwester
und betreuen vorfeld einer ambulanz eine
beatmungs notwendige patientin sie haben
mit anderen kolleginnen einen appell
oder besser gesagt einen hilferuf an den
bundesgesundheitsminister gesandt dazu
kommen wir noch sie sind so was wie
systemrelevant sie sind systemrelevant
wie sieht ein ganz normaler alltag ein
ganz normaler arbeitstag von einer
pflegenden krankenschwester in berlin
auf ja er so ich muss erstmal dazu sagen
also vor vier wochen waren wir noch
empathisch und jetzt sind wir plötzlich
systemrelevant also das ist schon mal
etwas was schon mal eine besserung ist
weil wir waren auch vor vier wochen
schon systemrelevant und das muss ich
bitte ihn vor jahren in die gesellschaft
in die köpfe setzen dass es sehr sehr
wichtig ist dass das pflege gibt dass es
uns gibt und im moment sieht es sehr
schwer für uns alle aus also
pflegekräfte laufen momentan maximal am
limit wir versuchen unsere versorgungen
zu halten
menschen die im krankenhaus arbeiten
werden vorbereitet dass eventuell kurve
patienten kommen menschen die in der
ambulanz arbeiten versuchen schon mal
die versorgung und umzustellen um
patienten die besonders gefährdet sind
zu schützen
in altenheim wiederum müssen die
menschen auch geschützt werden gerade
alte menschen müssen stark geschützt
werden damit die pflegekräfte halt nicht
die viren über träger werden also wir
haben massive probleme wir haben massive
material not auch in deutschland und es
ist absolut wichtig dass wir im moment
maximal unterstützt werden und nochmal
die frage von wann bis wann arbeiten sie
verfolgt wie sieht ihre schicht aus also
ich arbeite von 8 bis 20 uhr wir haben
zwölf schichten
das ist aber auch im bereich wo so
gearbeitet wird aus frankfurt ist uns
jetzt zugeschaltet frau professor dr
sandra zeck leiterin des instituts für
medizinische virologie an der uniklinik
frau die sich an den guten abend
natürlich auch zu ihnen
wer so vielen menschen in deutschland
derartige opfer zumutet der muss
natürlich irgendwann den nachweis
antreten dass sich das auch lohnt dass
sich das rechnet was glauben sie wann
haben wir diesen nach harz das wäre dann
der nachweis dass die anzahl der
neuinfektionen abnimmt und das wird
sicherlich noch einige wochen dauern
oder mindestens 14 tage nach beginn
dieser maßnahmen dauern
und das ist natürlich schwer zu
beurteilen weil wir natürlich auch keine
kontrollgruppe haben über das
normalerweise in der wissenschaft haben
aber ich hoffe dass einfach die nächsten
wochen zeigen dass unsere maßnahmen auch
zu einem erfolg führen und die
neuinfektionen zurückgehen
mit einem politiker der korona fast
schon durchgestanden hat sind wir jetzt
auch via skype verbunden
alexander graf lambsdorff einen guten
abend natürlich auch zu ihnen von berlin
nach berlin geht unser groß sie sind
fast durch durch die quarantäne sie
waren und sind noch infiziert wie sind
sie durch diese zeit gekommen
na ja am anfang war das nicht so schön
erstmal erschrickt man sich bei der
diagnose wald so eine neue krankheit ist
man weiß nicht recht was passiert dann
kamen grippesymptome also fieber
gliederschmerzen abgeschlagenheit wie
man das so kennt das war nicht sehr
schön aber das ging relativ schnell weg
dann kam es noch mal leichter wieder so
ein bisschen wellenförmig und ich muss
sagen ich habe großes glück gehabt wenn
ich das vergleiche mit manchen anderen
menschen die eigentlich auch gesund sind
ohne vorerkrankungen und trotzdem
schwerere verläufe haben als ich das
hatte und ich habe eine gute nachricht
für anderthalb stunden erfahren dass ich
negativ getestet worden bin also
vielleicht endet die quarantäne
irgendwann das gesundheitsamt will
wahrscheinlich einen zweiten test aber
das war der berühmte zweite test da ist
schon mal große freude unterwegs wer hat
für sie eingekauft wie sind sie über den
tag gekommen 24 stunden lang man schläft
auch schlechter irgendwie ja also
eingekauft haben für mich meine nachbarn
und ich finde es ist nicht zeit in der
es auch die nachbarn und gute
nachbarschaft ankommt das sind hier in
berlin ich durfte ja nicht zurück in den
wahlkreis einen ein pärchen gegenüber
die klopfen an die tür standen dann in
ihrer wurde und rief mir aus der wohnung
zu gern gelesen dass sie krank sind
sollte ihnen das mitbringen und so
musste ich also nicht hungern und mit
wunderbar versorgt worden
dann auch von freunden und familie das
hat wirklich gut geklappt und den
tagesablauf ist natürlich schon ein
anderer mann ist ganz alleine ich musste
wie damals als student für mich selber
kochen drei mahlzeiten am tag
das strukturierte ansonsten gab es viele
videokonferenzen telefonschalten so
macht man diese und so ungefähr stellt
man es sich vor sie sind graf lambsdorff
wenn ich das so sagen darf politiker und
betroffene glauben sie nach dem was sie
wissen was sie natürlich gelesen haben
erfahren haben auch von ihren kollegen
dass das jetzt schon der richtige
zeitpunkt ist darüber nachzudenken
diese einschränkungen auch zu lockern
ich glaube man muss beides tun wir
müssen das tun dass wir im bundestag in
dieser woche gemacht haben nämlich die
hilfspakete auf den weg bringen
insbesondere für die krankenhäuser für
betroffene menschen auch für die
wirtschaft wir müssen aber gleichzeitig
schon überlegen gibt es irgendwann auch
wieder einen silberstreif am horizont
für menschen für unternehmen
das ist eine diskussion die wir schon
führen müssten aber immer nur wenn das
möglich ist und ich will das hier
deutlich sagen dass eine diskussion die
wir in der politik in der gesellschaft
führen die auch in den medien geführt
wird von journalisten aber das letzte
wort was geht haben die ärzte haben die
infektiologen haben die epidemiologen
ich glaube es wäre ganz falsch
hinzugehen wie beispielsweise donald
trump und einfach zu erklären
am ostersonntag sind die kirchen voll
das ist unsinn das kann kein politiker
entscheiden
wir brauchen den naturwissenschaftlichen
rats dafür und trotzdem es ja die sorge
gerade beiden liberalen groß dass wir
vielleicht mehr kaputt machen als wir
lösen
ihr parteichef christian lindner hat
jetzt explizit eine exit strategie
gefordert haben sie hat er schon eine
idee nein er hat das ja auch
konditioniert und hat ganz klar gesagt
die einschränkungen die wir jetzt haben
sind verhältnismäßig sie sind richtig
dass hatte andrew ullmann ja genau wie
karl lauterbach eben auch gesagt da gibt
es im bundestag eine große einigkeit und
dass christian linder dann gesagt hat
ist wir müssen aber trotzdem mal
überlegen welche voraussetzungen müssen
erfüllt sein damit es möglich wird wie
der erleichterungen zu schaffen also
diese voraussetzungen darum einmal zu
reden
ich glaube das ist wichtig vergessen wir
bitte eines nicht wir haben eine
wirtschaft die wirklich werden es gerade
gesehen auf den knien ist wir haben auch
ganz viele schülerinnen und schülern die
ihre abschlüsse machen müssen
abiturienten die jetzt nicht
unterrichtet werden können auch in der
mittleren reife die vorbereitung auf die
abschlüsse
also wann es geht wenn es
epidemiologisch okay ist wenn die
gesundheit nicht gefährdet wird wenn man
den infektionsschutz einhalten kann
dafür dann für den zeitpunkt schon eine
strategie zu haben ist besser als erst
in dem zeitpunkt anzufangen darüber
nachzudenken
wir werden nochmal genau schauen was
christian lender gesagt ich will an der
stelle erst mal ganz herzlich danke
sagen
natürlich gute gesundheit wünschen am
besten spontanheilung das war schon mal
eine gute nachricht ja also gerade eben
hieß ist noch alles für die gesundheit
alles für das gesundheitswesen und nun
gibt es tatsächlich schon politiker die
wenigstens eine kosten nutzen rechnung
aufmachen wollen für die gesamte
volkswirtschaft und unseren staat wird
der schaden nachhaltig und über
jahrzehnte nicht kompensierbar sein wenn
wir nicht spätestens nach ostern die
wirtschaft wieder schrittweise
hochfahren und auch fdp chef christian
lindner mahnt der aktuelle zustand
widerspricht der menschlichen natur
mit dem heutigen tag muss es deshalb
darum gehen diesen zustand schritt für
schritt aber so schnell wie möglich zu
überwinden
ja ja immer noch mal die frage ab dem
heutigen tag der war gestern schritt für
schritt diesen zustand wieder überwinden
da würde man jetzt sagen so denkt
mancher fdp-politiker aber
offensichtlich auch schon kollegen der
cdu
was glauben sie wielange kann man da
noch den druck unter dem kessel halten
die man muss jetzt das mal primär die
prioritäten klar sehen dass die
gesundheit hier im vordergrund steht und
da sind die zahlen momentan noch sehr
beunruhigend weil die zunahme der
infektionszahlen die wir jetzt täglich
noch wahrnehmen hier sehr stark ist und
die maßnahmen die gerade das pro paar
tagen ergriffen worden sind werde
frühestens in der nächsten woche auch
wirklich erkennen aber nichtsdestotrotz
wir haben ja pandemiepläne wir bereiten
uns auf eine pandemie hervor
deswegen ist es auch durchaus auch
legitim auch eine excel stellen sich zu
überlegen welche schritte müssen wir
jetzt gehen um dann wieder putzen
normalität zurückzukehren und ich denke
das ist auch richtig dass man darüber
nachdenkt fragen wir nochmal die
virologin frau zech ist das vorstellbar
dass man einzelne betriebe dass man auch
die schulen zum beispiel für die
oberschüler wieder eröffnet oder für die
grundschüler oder dass man darüber
nachdenkt auch die kindergärten da wo es
möglich ist
zu öffnen halten sie so was für denkbar
ja ich denke dass das schon denkbar ist
ich denke man muss jetzt erstmal schauen
satz dass sich die fallzahlen
stabilisieren und dann muss man wie
schon die kollegen gesagt haben
natürlich planen was als nächstes
passiert und als nächstes ist dann
darüber nachzudenken dass man bestimmte
personengruppen wieder dem öffentlichen
leben zu führt und das sind die die
natürlich kein risiko haben also nicht
die älteren oder nicht die mit
vorerkrankungen zum beispiel diese
überlegungen gibt die oberstufenschüler
frage auch an frau aigner geben
wie kommt ihnen diese diskussion vor die
kliniken bereiten sich gerade auf das
schlimmste vor sie rechnen mit dem
schlimmsten und man denkt jetzt
tatsächlich schon darüber nach wie kann
man danach justieren wie kann man es für
alle ein bisschen lebbare machen hat das
auch etwas mit der psyche zu tun dass
man einfach die hoffnung stirbt zuletzt
braucht man das ja die seele spielt ja
immer eine große rolle in kritischen
momenten und ich glaube dass es im
moment immer so systemfragen gibt also
alle sind plötzlich systemrelevant und
ich glaube dass im moment uns klar sein
muss das erstmal das system
gesundheitswesen absolut gestärkt werden
muss damit die anderen systeme geschützt
werden und ich glaube da müssen wir den
fokus drauf packen um danach dann zu
sagen jetzt können die anderen systeme
wieder anfangen sich zu bewegen und ich
glaube da müssen wir wirklich drauf
achten weil ich glaube dass die
krankenhäuser und die pflege und die
ärzte moment maximal hilfe brauchen
frage auch an herrn lauterbach kann man
das ist natürlich richtig kann man jetzt
trotzdem darüber nachdenken oder wie
muss man sich vorstellen dass es
irgendwie eine quarantäne gibt für
bestimmte risikogruppen immer mal wieder
einen shutdown gibt dass man bestimmte
gruppen der bevölkerung wieder nach
draußen lässt sind der strategien die
jetzt schon gedacht werden als zunächst
ich bin nicht der meinung dass man über
die strategie reden soll wenn man kein
ziel hat und
kann ja im prinzip drei ziele verfolgen
davon hängt auf die strategie ab das
muss nachher politisch entschieden
werden
das ist keine entscheidung die
wissenschaftler der zu treffen können
sondern kann er nur beraten und die drei
also unterschiedlichen ziele die man
verfolgen könnte wer zum einen also ich
infiziert mal oder erlaube dass sich
diejenigen die wenige risikofaktoren
haben infizieren und schütze diejenigen
die alt sind und die risikofaktoren
haben
die zweite strategie ist also ich
erlaube so zu sagen dass das virus sich
langsam in der bevölkerung ausbreitet
aber nie so schnell also dass also die
kapazitäten in den intensiv
medizinischen abteilungen überlastet
sind
das heißt ich schleiche langsam an die
60 70 prozent der infizierten heran und
ob es ohne dabei immer sozusagen das
system so stark dass es eine überlastung
gibt dass wir zur möglichkeit zwei und
möglichkeit 30 versuche so wenige in der
bevölkerung zur infektion zu bringen wie
möglich bis es eine impfung gibt das
haus ich ziele gar nicht also sozusagen
darauf ab das system nicht zu überlassen
sondern bleibe so weit wie möglich
darunter und habe dann nachher 10 oder
15 prozent der bevölkerung die infiziert
war
wenn also die aussagen mal impfung kommt
das ist die strengsten strategie
das ist die die ich als die einzige
richtige finde obwohl die wenig
diskutiert wird die erste strategie ist
extrem gefährlich und zwar deshalb wenn
ich nachher nur noch diejenigen habt und
diese risikofaktoren haben oder alt sind
und die kommen dann aus der isolation
heraus und werden dann krank dann sind
all die ich schwer sagen wir gefährdet
sind gleichzeitig krank das schlägt kann
wissenschaftler vor das fett weg somit
ist eigentlich nur zwischen strategie
zwei und drei und diese strategie zwei
dass ich das ziel ab also ich locker
immer so weit dass ich gerade die
intensivstation nicht überlastet das
halte ich für nicht vertretbar und zwar
deshalb weil dabei vergessen wird wie
extrem gefährlich das virus auch für
diejenigen ist die nicht verstärken
wir denken immer einsamer plus oder
minus derjenige der sozusagen stirbt ist
gestorben
derjenige der überlebt ist danach wieder
voll gesund
aber das war es zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
niemand wir haben hinweise darauf dass
auch diejenigen die nicht versterben und
sah man nur eine pneumonie gehabt haben
diese typische pneumonie die sehr
spezifisch für die zahlungen entzündung
kann genau lungenentzündung dass die zum
teil auch bleibende schäden behalten
werden und außerdem ist es so dass worte
ullmann bestätigen wollen wenn ich einen
älteren menschen auch wenn er überlebt
längere zeit beatmet habe er kommt in
der regel aus der beatmung nicht mehr so
raus wie er reingegangen ist also
niemand kann also kliniker also
unterschätzt die bedeutung an der
längeren welche drei prozent der
menschen außer die infiziert werden zum
schluss warten muss es auf der
intensivstation habe dann sind viele
dieser menschen danach dauerhaft
beschädigt was ihr gehirn angeht was ihr
herz angeht also was anfälligkeit an die
verlieren sehr viel muskelmasse
daher halte ich also die frage nach der
strategie für zach und der ich muss
jetzt mal wissen was für ein ziel habe
ich und ich wäre sehr viel strenger
daher finde ich die debatte jetzt die
maßnahmen zu locker und wissen der
lehman vorgestanden
die finde ich völlig fehl am platz also
ich glaube wir unterschätzen nach wie
vor die konsequenzen die das auch wie
für erkrankte der hanseaten lesen
überleben also die konsequenzen auch für
jüngere leute die erkrankt sind schwer
erkrankt sind und es überleben diese
konsequenzen müssen auch bedenken und
die leute haben wir bisher nie gefragt
sei der bereit dieses risiko zu gehen
das ist aus meiner sicht was in der
debatte derzeit fehlt was fehlt deshalb
ist richtig dass sie darauf aufmerksam
machen wir fragen frau zach freut sich
erste logische frage die erstmal komisch
klingt oder bizarr klingt kann es auch
eine gefahr sein wenn sich zu wenig
menschen infizieren genauso prägen jetzt
die herdenimmunität an wenn wir es eben
auch schon angeklungen ist und zwar ist
es bei dieser erkrankung so dass es ja
bisher keine immunität in der
bevölkerung gibt und wenn man 70 prozent
infizierte hätte dann spricht man
ungefähr 70 von herrn immunität und dann
könnte man natürlich dadurch die älteren
oder die mit frau erkrankung schützen
das ist aber sehe ich genauso wie mein
vorredner ein problem bei dieser
erkrankung denn gerade wir sehen ja auch
das junge patienten schwer erkranken und
die auch keine vorerkrankung haben und
natürlich wäre das sehr unethisch wenn
man jetzt einfach sagen würde um einen
herdenimmunität zu erreichen würden wir
jetzt einfach einen maßnahmen einstellen
und das vieh ziel verfolgen das sehe ich
genauso
wir haben viele fragen auch wieder zu
dieser sendung bekommen beispielsweise
wurden zuschauer wissen wer jetzt
richtig vorsichtig ist wer sich alles
hält der erkrankt später und später sind
vielleicht die intensivbetten schon voll
ist dann also der anständige der dumme
was schwierig in dieser situation ich
denke im moment kann man nicht wirklich
sagen was ist jetzt richtig oder falsch
weil man halt auch abwägen muss und wir
müssen halt auch einfach noch mal daran
denken dass wir nicht wirklich und
schützen können weil uns schutz
materialien einfach fehlen in
deutschland und damit haben wir schon
mal ein anderes problem also wir
versuchen schutz zu betreiben ohne dass
wir ausreichend schutz materialien haben
und dazu kommen wir auf jeden fall noch
wichtig ist jetzt auch im evaluieren
wichtiges thema viel zu wichtiges thema
im evaluieren natürlich welche rolle
diese tests spielen können wenn sie uns
dann noch mal helfen es gibt
verschiedene tests die bhu empfiehlt
jetzt testen testen testen wird richtig
getestet bei uns soll tatsächlich am
ende dann doch nur der zum test gehen
der schon symptome hat was sagt die
biologin in frankfurt genau also es gibt
verschiedene teste das wissen wir es
gibt den test auf pc
das heißt der genom nachweis vom virus
also das erbgut und hier gibt es einige
neuerungen es gibt jetzt seit dieser
woche einen test der auf so genannten
vollautomaten laufen kann das dazu führt
dass wir auf großgeräten wie zb
blutspendediensten stehen aber auch in
biologie viel mehr tests durchführen
und nicht so viel personal dafür
brauchen die es aber das problem oder
die einschränkung zu sagen dass die
firma natürlich auch nur soviel tests
herstellen kann wie sie schafft und
diese anzahl der tests begrenzt ist die
kapazitäten die diese vollautomaten
haben sind irgendwann größer als das was
wir an test zur verfügung stehen haben
was noch neu ist und im april kommen
wird sind sogenannte katholischen tests
sind so eine art of care tests
das ist dass man einen patienten testen
kann
das kann man zum beispiel in
notaufnahmen direkt machen und das
dauert ungefähr nur eine stunde und dann
hat man auch am pc basiertes ergebnis
hier muss man aber auch einschränkend
sagen dass das eine einzelleistung ist
und dass die sehr teuer sind und die
sind vor allen dingen für den einsatz im
krankenhaus gedacht also wenn sie in der
notaufnahme sind und entscheiden müssen
muss der patient in den teil der mit
patienten mit saas corona virus zwei
infektionen ja belegt ist oder muss er
einen teil der nicht infizierten und um
das möglichst schnell zu entscheiden
sind diese tests geeignet für den
ambulanten bereich ist es so dass wir
wie gesagt durch die verschiedenen tests
sie verschiedene firmen jetzt auf den
markt bringen sich die lage natürlich
ein bisschen entspannt aber immer noch
zu wenig test geht's einfach produziert
werden um alle zu testen die sage ich
mal nur leichte symptome oder gar keine
symptome haben und dass es dann unsere
aufgabe ja auch zu schauen wo sind die
tests am sinnvollsten also wo gibt es
eine medizinische relevanz für den test
wie zb bei patienten die stationär
liegen oder zum beispiel beim ärztlichen
personal oder bei den pflegepersonal
dass man die natürlich testen muss um
möglichst zu vermeiden dass die wiederum
patienten anstecken und mir gleich dann
abwägen wie viel test kits können zur
verfügung zur verfügung gestellt werden
das haben sie sicherlich auch verfolgt
bessere test schnellere test test
vielleicht die man auch an sich selbst
machen kann
würde das auch erst mal die situation
des klinikpersonals oder auch ihre in
der ambulanten pflege für einfach ja na
klar also wenn ich weiß ich bin
infiziert dann weiß ich natürlich wie
ich mich zu schützen haben
und da wir im moment kein schutz
material haben bedeutet das dass ich
nicht zur arbeit gehen kann wenn schutz
material da ist und ich symptomlos bin
dann ist das ja gelockert worden vom
robert koch institut die regel
dann kann ich arbeiten aber ich muss die
richtigen schutz materialien haben also
ist es soll ja also ist es notwendig
dass medizinisches personal insbesondere
pflegefachpersonal die besonders engen
patientenkontakt haben geprüft getestet
werden dass wir überhaupt die
einrichtungen schützen können und ich
spreche hier ganz besonders von den
altenpflegeeinrichtungen klappt und die
sind viele an der zahl und es betrifft
insgesamt 900.000 menschen ältere
mitbürger und natürlich auch 700.000
menschen die pflege frage letzte frage
an sie impfstoffe medikamente auch diese
sehnsucht ist groß worauf setzen sie am
allermeisten momentan also ich denke man
muss auf beides setzen ich denke bei den
impfstoff entwicklungen sind alle die
sich damit beschäftigen und die da
erfahrung haben dabei das zu versuchen
einen impfstoff zu entwickeln aber das
wird einfach dauern der muss ja auch
erst getestet werden der muss effizient
sein muss sicher sein
mit einem großen mengen produziert
werden und das wird einfach noch ein
jahr sicherlich dauern also ich schätze
dass das im jahr mindestens dauern wird
und dass andere worauf wir bauen ist
natürlich wenn jemand in vier infiziert
ist dass wir antivirale medikamente
haben die man dann einsetzen kann und
hier haben wir jetzt in frankfurt zb
zusammen mit dem fraunhofer institut in
hamburg der gibt es ein screening bord
haben wir ganz viele substanzen getestet
die schon zugelassen sind als
medikamente für andere indikationen oder
aber in der klinischen prüfung waren und
wenn man so ein medikament identifiziert
was dann auch eine wirkung gegen saas
corona virus 2 hätte wäre einfach
der vorteil dass wir das schon kennen
wissen wie wir das einsetzen müssen und
ja eigentlich direkt ein heilversuch
oder technische studien starten könnten
und das ist meine große hoffnung dass
wir da einen hit finden also ein treffer
finden die der möglichst zeitnah dann
weiter einsetzen können bei erkrankten
frau professor jack einen ganz
herzlichen dank nach frankfurt danke
dass sie uns zur verfügung gestanden
haben
und damit sind wir bei dem thema das die
ganze zeit schon mit schwangen nämlich
material und personal denn dieses
gesundheitswesen wird beides brauchen
schutz material muss er wenn wir damit
anfangen und zwar für die ärzte für die
hausärzte für auch zahnärzte für alle
klinikärzte und natürlich für das
pflegepersonal not produktion 75 jahre
nach dem letzten krieg
heute fehlen keine waffen es fehlt an
schutzkleidung und medizintechnik die
deutsche wirtschaft reagiert albstadt
baden württemberg statt des und
badehosen net die firma jetzt
mundschutzmasken die nachfrage von
kliniken praxen und pflegeeinrichtungen
sei enorm
zwischenzeitlich werden wir natürlich
überflutet von anfragen die wir jetzt
schon gar nicht mehr erfüllen können
allein gestern hätten wir 3 millionen
masken an den mann bringen können
auf atemschutzmasken spezialisiert ist
die firma moll decks aus der nähe von
tübingen statt an die industrie zu
liefern versorgen sie jetzt medizin und
pflegepersonal auch volkswagen und bmw
wollen medizinisches gerät produzieren
teile für beatmungsgeräte aus 3d
druckern ja und damit sind wir bei der
frage herum man eines der besten
gesundheitssysteme der welt scheint zu
scheitern an einen weg artikeln ob wir
jetzt daran scheitern kann ich im
augenblick nicht beurteilen aber die
zahlen sind schon besorgniserregend
ich habe gerade aus meiner eigenen
heimatstadt erfahren dass in der
uniklinik möglicherweise ein
schutzkittel für knapp zwei wochen
vorhanden sind und sagen jetzt
lieferungen auf dem weg gestern hat der
minister sparen bei uns im
gesundheitsausschuss auch gesagt es sind
materialien auf dem weg nach deutschland
aber die haben ein bisschen sehr knapp
kalkuliert meine meinung nach in der
vorbereitung auf diese pandemie frau
aigner ihre petition an den
gesundheitsminister an jens spahn
enthält das drastische wort
kanonenfutter
warum haben sie und ihre kollegen den
eindruck dass sie an der front sind und
verheizt werden naja das flattert ja
momentan immer durch die medien also
durch die medien also wir haben wir
haben uns scheinbar irgendwie dazu
entschieden dass wir eine pandemie
abwehrmitte krieg sprache machen das
gefällt uns eigentlich nicht so gut weil
wir machen eigentlich eine
gesundheitsfördernde maßnahme grad
seines vorsorge know daseinsvorsorge und
deswegen haben wir das benutzt und für
uns ist es so wenn wir ungeschützt in
den einrichtungen arbeiten müssen
dann können wir uns infizieren und
können auch daran versterben so wie es
auch in anderen ländern passiert ist und
italien sind ist sehr viel medizinisches
und pflegerisches personal verstorben
auch in china in spanien wohl auch und
das kann uns auch passieren in
deutschland lag auch eine altenpflegerin
bereits auf der intensivstation und hat
um ihr leben gekämpft
und deswegen ist es unabdingbar dass wir
schutzkleidung bekommen um nicht
kanonenfutter zu werden und um die
daseinsvorsorge voranzutreiben
es ist echt bitter der heinsberger
landrat hat peking herr lauterbach der
halbe lauterbach direkt um hilfe gebeten
ist das peinlich für ihn oder peinlich
für deutschland ist peinlich für uns
natürlich und man muss sagen wir sind ja
in verschiedenen bereichen der medizin
mittlerweile auf china und indien
angewiesen
nach dieser krise kann es auf keinen
fall so bleiben
und man muss auch selbstkritisch sagen
also die asiatischen länder haben nach
den beiden ausbrüchen 2002/2003 und 2013
genommen haben die gelernt und haben
also daher ehrlich gesagt also
insbesondere teilbaren singapur die sind
sehr gut also sagen wir bisher über die
runden kommt das problem auch noch nicht
gelöst aber dass wir also in kürze eine
gigantische knappheit an material
befürchten müssen
und wenn die amerikaner das problem
richtig hart bekommen werden die den
markt mit ihrer massiven geld und aktien
power versuchen leerzukaufen bis dahin
müssen wir vorbereitet sein denn ich
glaube dass in wenigen wochen das sind
ja nicht nur masken schutzkleidung sind
auch andere dienste lektion smedins los
rät auch material nicht jeder der
beatmet wird also ist sofort da
handlungsbedarf bedürftiger braucht ein
medikament sprühen medikament das da
sind wir auch auf das ausland angewiesen
somit es kann gut sein wenn in drei
wochen in amerika die katastrophe sich
entwickelt dass dann der komplette markt
leer gekauft wird
und wenn wir bis dahin nicht unsere
eigenen auszusagen
die lage geklärt haben und hochgefahren
sind dann können wir auch neuen große
probleme kommen sie haben das alles
verfolgt arztpraxen telefonieren jetzt
mit baumärkten recherchieren online
versuchen noch zu dem letzten rest zu
kommen es war immer die rede davon
dass der bund das koordinieren will
macht er das schafft er das also ich
würde sagen dass ich hoffe dass der
winter schafft ich hoffe dass der bund
das schafft wir kriegen gemischte
signale
und es wäre unehrlich zu sagen also dass
wir da jetzt schon sicher sagen können
dass das funktioniert das wie eine
unehrliche aussage die also es muss auf
jeden fall jetzt noch viel mehr
appelliert werden auch an die genutzten
übrigens in der hinsicht ist auch klar
dass wir uns klar festlegen müssen waren
lockern wir oder nicht denn wenn die
firmen wissen dass wir tatsächlich
versuchen lange zeit die zahl der
infizierten sehr niedrig zu halten
dann werden auch viel mehr firmen die
produktion einsteigen dann weiß ich dass
wird hier ein markt werden der sehr
lange anhält werden jetzt so eine
diskussion kommen den zwei wochen wird
das schon gelockert aber dahin oder
andere denken dann lohnt es sich nicht
dass ich da noch ein steige müsse ein
klares signal geben an die industrie wir
werden versuchen das lange durchzuhalten
er baut jetzt auch was ihr könnt und die
beschaffung durch den bund da also ist
es jetzt nicht so wie möglich zu sagen
dass wir es schaffen können
aber es ist auf jeden fall alles
unternommen der arbeiten auch alle
parteien zusammen kann